Mì vậy thống bây giờ, tự nhiên, mì đã thông qua kể vật cách giảm nhanh sách theo để sất của tổng thống đúng nân trâm.
Trong đó, hơn chính tỷ đồ là Mỹ bị các khỏi các chuyện trận nước ngoài và hệ thống chuyện thông công cơm.
Kể hoặc được thông qua với năm mối phía thuận và bối mới tạm phía trống.
Cú thể, khoảng tạm tỷ đồ là Mỹ đến trở chuyện nước ngoài.
Chủ yếu dốt quán phát triển của tế Mỹ USA, khoảng lý sẽ bị lợi vỏ.
Thêm một tỷ đồ là Mỹ khác bị các khỏi nhanh sách dành cho hơn một tỷ năm trăm đại phát thành.
Và chuyện hiện kiểu phương trình khắp nước Mỹ, nên là lần khi em hoài của Mỹ đồng ý các nynh sách đã được vừa chất đó.
Các hệ này tưởng đồ xây dựng bởi bộ hiệu quả triển phủ đồ G,
nơi tỷ của LMS từng lạnh gạo trước khi ông giờ chính phủ hồi tháng 6, giò vẫn đồng bởi tổng thống trăm.
Chất đó, hà viện tưởng đều sất các thêm bụt trong chiều đồ là Mỹ từ các chuyện trình y tế thuận câu,
nhưng để sân ngày đã bị phản đối và được loại bỏ hỏi dựu lột quay cùng.
Hình vẫn bản đăng được chuyển lại hà viện để xem xe lực quay,
chí tiền theo kế hoài ngân sách bằng đầu.